[Música]
salud en directo América de France 24
más Romero sala está en nuestro estudio
para hablar de una relación mar que
existe entre la flora intestinal y la
depresión No si parece sorprendente pero
cada vez hay más evidencia que relaciona
esta flora intestinal o la microbiota
también cómo se llama con la Salud
Mental la salud en general no estamos
hablando de todos esos microorganismos
que viven en nuestro intestino por
ejemplo las bacterias para
para entender No estos estudios que se
han publicado recientemente en la
revista en hecho y que relaciona la
depresión con este tipo de bacterias
estamos con Oscar Franco director del
departamento de salud pública de la
Universidad de utrecht que nos acompaña
hoy como otros días en esta sección
doctor hablábamos de estos estudios no
que tienen que ver con esta serie de
bacterias que están relacionadas con la
Salud Mental en este caso con la
depresión cuéntenos Cuáles son estas
bacterias Y qué relevancia tienen
si son los dos estudios más grandes que
se han publicado hasta este momento son
estudios que fueron realizados aquí en
los Países Bajos uno en ámsterdam el
otro en róterdam y que evalúan el efecto
de microbioma entonces lo que nos
muestran los resultados Más allá de
bacterias específicas lo que nos muestra
son como digamos grupos o familias de
bacterias que se encontraron 13 familias
específicas que estaban relacionados con
los síntomas depresivos familias Como
por ejemplo de coprocos o se limona u
otros que ya se habían reportado en
otros estudios pero que estos estas dos
publicaciones confirman y que afectan
están relacionados con síntomas
depresivos Más allá de factores como
estilo de vida o como de la de La Raza o
del lugar donde viven las personas
doctor muy buen día y le pregunto porque
hay un vínculo entonces entre estas
bacterias y la depresión
hay que entender que dentro de nosotros
vive este universo que es el el
microbioma la microbiota que son los
microorganismos que viven dentro de
diferentes partes de nuestro cuerpo Como
por ejemplo en este caso es el intestino
y lo que sucede es que ellos actúan y
ayudan a modular la producción de
ciertas sustancias por ejemplo
neurotransmisores que son como las
palabras que utiliza el sistema nervioso
para poder comunicarse pero también la
respuesta inmune y también la respuesta
inflamatoria y la depresión se ha
relacionado con múltiples factores no
solamente con los neurotransmisores sino
también con la respuesta inmune y con
una inflamación Crónica entonces es
posible que estos grupos de bacterias
pueden estar relacionados y una y un
desorden en ese en ese equilibrio que
debe tener el microbiota la microbiota
Pues podría generar que no solamente se
produzcan de una manera inadecuada los
neurotransmisores sino que se produzca
una respuesta inflamatoria crónica
inadecuada
doctor estamos diciendo que hay este
vínculo no está esta relación Yo quería
preguntarle si sabemos con certeza si es
que este desorden o desequilibrio en la
microbiota es una causa o es una
consecuencia de que las personas
padezcan depresión por ejemplo
esto no lo tenemos muy claro lo que
sabemos es que el microbioma y la
microbiota se desarrollan a través de
nuestra vida desde el momento en que
nacemos a través de la lactancia de lo
que estamos comiendo entonces
se requerirían estudios que se pudieran
evaluar desde muy largo tiempo para ver
qué ocurre primero pero por ahora lo que
parece indicar es que esa relación
podría ser de una característica causal
pero aún eso se tiene que investigar y
confirmar doctor le pregunto si cabe la
posibilidad de que todo esto derive en
algún tipo de terapia clínica
la confirmación de este Universo de esa
flora intestinal que vive dentro de
nosotros y en los estudios que estamos
haciendo en este tema Pues podría ayudar
no solamente identificar mecanismos o
entender mejor como las enfermedades
ocurren sino que podría también
llevarnos a confirmar el papel Por
ejemplo que la dieta puede jugar en
nuestra salud sabemos que la dieta es el
factor más importante que está
relacionado con él con el microbioma y
también se ha hablado de trasplantes de
heces o trasplantes de microbiota fecal
pero que eso se puede considerar yo creo
que
en unos cuantos años o más mediano o
largo plazo y que podría también
constituir una una alternativa para para
terapia para tratamientos primero
resolver las dudas y luego ver qué
hacemos con esas respuestas doctor para
terminar yo quería preguntarle no este
vínculo entre el sistema nervioso y el
sistema digestivo se ha hablado
ampliamente No de hecho se llega a veces
a llamarle el segundo cerebro al sistema
digestivo o al intestino Cuál es este
vínculo
si hay una comunicación bidireccional
tanto del sistema nervioso central o el
cerebro y y lo que está ocurriendo en el
intestino la producción de
neurotransmisores esa comunicación es
bidireccional se relacionado por ejemplo
que la composición del microbioma en el
intestino puede afectar la cognición
puede afectar el afecto entonces lo que
estamos es entendiendo relaciones
bastante complejas que antes pensábamos
que eran mucho más simples y unas
comunicaciones que ocurren entre
nuestros órganos y nuestros tejidos que
hasta ahora Estamos confirmando y
descubriendo y que todavía Abre muchas
avenidas para posibles para entender
mejor Qué causa y cómo se causan las
enfermedades Y cómo las podemos tratar
doctor Muchísimas gracias por toda la
información o como siempre Un abrazo
gracias por acompañarnos